authorities in the Dominican Republic
say they're closing in on the mastermind
behind the shooting of Red Sox legend
David Big Papi Ortiz police have
identified a suspect they described as a
middleman who paid the hit men that
attacked Ortiz at a Santo Domingo bar
ole ole ng is in the dominican capital
Molen what do we know about the latest
suspect
well Dominican authorities say the
suspect Alberto Miguel Rodriguez Mota is
a known fugitive he was the one
authorities say allegedly paid nearly
eight thousand dollars to have Ortiz
killed yesterday a judge held a closed
hearing for another suspect
Gabrielle Alexander Perez visca II know
Perez Miss Calle know whose nickname is
Bone and turned himself in to
authorities on Friday he allegedly met
with the gunmen at a gas station before
the shooting to show him a photo of the
target Dominican officials have not
confirmed whether that photo was in fact
of David Ortiz so far Perez visca a no
is the tenth person detained in
connection to the attack the Dominican
police are still looking for at least
four other suspects including the plots
mastermind the man who paid for the hit
the source of the money an attorney for
David Ortiz says that Ortiz is happy so
far with how the investigation is going
and of course as we know Ortiz continues
to recover at a hospital in Boston in
intensive care
Adriana well Angie thank you my family's
from the Dominican Republic and I just
got a message of my cousin saying people
there are so worried about what's
happening in the country and of course
how Americans are feeling about it we're
perceiving it absolutely it's a huge PR
problem